good morning believe nation today's
message is compete for victory over to
you Ayrton Senna
I wake up every mood this recipe we go
you should know that by being a racing
driver you are on the risk all the time
by being a racing driver means you are
racing with other people and if you no
longer go for a gap that exists you no
longer a racing driver because we are
competing we are competing to win and
and the main motivation to all of us is
to compete for a victory is not to
concern for 346 so I love the idea of
competition I feel like having a nemesis
having somebody here going up against
makes you better as an entrepreneur and
pushes you to be the best version of
yourself alia had fraser biggie had to
pack Batman had the Joker Kanye had 50
cent you know people have nemesis's that
make them be the best version of
themselves so I'm part of an agency that
represents me that has me booked out on
speaking gigs and book deals and that
kind of stuff and when I first started
the agency I told steve the owner that I
would be the number one person at the
agency on YouTube that was a focus that
they're trying to grow and it was one
guy ahead of me and so that guy became
my nemesis and for two years I was
trying to catch him and beat him and
force me to do better videos and I was
tracking my numbers his numbers and
watching the growth every month and now
I passed him and it's kind of a letdown
because now it's like well who else do I
go after who else should be my new
nemesis because once you reach that goal
there's a little bit of a letdown the
figure it well where do I go next but
having that challenge forced me to
continue innovating and made me the best
version of myself and put out a lot of
great content that also helps you guys
and so having a nemesis for you having a
competition for you and being able to
track that on a regular basis can help
you be the best version of yourself as
an entrepreneur so my question of the
day is who is your nemesis who is the
individual or the company that you are
chasing down that you want to be better
than leave it in the comments below and
maybe part 2 or option A or B question
the day is who should my new
nemesis be my new target B since I
already beat the guy I was chasing who
should I be chasing next let me know
leave in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presso awake
expresso keep me going